[Music]
Dominique is with us in Allentown
Pennsylvania hi Dominique how are you
really good days things taking my call
sure what's up
so my parents did the Financial Peace
University years ago they were debt-free
for probably around three or four years
and the last two or three years they
started going back into debt again and
they just keep adding it up and they
really haven't been working towards
paying it off and I've been trying to
help them like make a plan and
everything and they're just not really
sounds like they have a plan is about it
yes it's not really it's scaring me
because I have a feeling that they're
not going to have a retirement when it
comes time yeah it's really one of the
most painful things are being an adult
is watching people you love do stupid
self-destructive things because the
problem is it's not illegal to be stupid
you can't have them arrested right and
and and and they're obviously not
listening to you right you've talked to
them
yeah they're just going to go ahead and
do stupid right pretty much no I I don't
know I mean I think the only thing you
can do is to do you know anybody that
what was it that got them into Financial
Peace University in the first place who
got them in I think is because they had
our church they they had a announcement
that they were having classes yeah that
was your pastor involved in all that I
believe so okay I'm just wondering if
your pastor could talk to them because
they're not gonna listen to you we've
already figured that out right mm-hmm
that's not unknown I have normal by the
way most parents don't listen to their
kids so it's hard to take advice from
your kids so but what I'm thinking is I
wonder if there's somebody else you
could speak into their life and give
them up give them a little cattle prods
shock them right somebody needs to shock
them and they're not listening to you so
like maybe a pastor smack him upside the
head in a loving pastoral kind of way
but you know that something needs to
happen otherwise you just got stand back
and mind your own business
I mean you could drop some hints here
and there if y'all ever want to get out
I'll pay for Financial Peace University
view to go back or I'll help you or
whatever but you're worried more about
it than they are